yo what's up everybody my Luigi here
with another Dark Souls 3 tutorial now
in this video I'm gonna be showing you
guys all 10 locations for the undead
bone shards in Dark Souls 3
the first undead bone shard can be found
in the overall area of the undead
settlement but close to the dilapidated
bridge bonfire from that bonfire heads
straight past the one big enemy with a
big saw and go to the graveyard of
arrows area once you get to this area be
sure you keep moving if this is your
first time here as there will be an
archer shooting these giant arrows at
you the bone shard is going to be on the
right of the area on some of the broken
ground and there are a lot of enemies
and arrows flying at you so you gotta
pick this one up fast unless you've been
through this area before and you've
calmed it down
undead bone shard 2 will be on the road
of sacrifices near the keep ruins
bonfire this is the swamp area and it's
pretty hectic and confusing so I'm going
to be putting up a map made by redditor
DJ Franza that allowed me to use in this
video I'm gonna show you guys the area
I'm talking about so from the keep ruins
bonfire you're going to turn right and
there's gonna be a tower with a ton of
slugs inside of it kill all the slugs or
don't the bone shard is in between all
limits the glowing item in the middle of
it all eight or ten or however many
there are the third one is going to be
at the Cathedral of the deep near the
Cathedral of the deep bonfire so you're
going to leave the bonfire run past all
of those white skeletons and keep going
until you reach the super giant
staircase you're not going to go up this
staircase before you're going to turn
right into the graveyard slash arrow
yard there's gonna be a lot of people to
either take this slowly and kill them
all or running quick like you see me do
the shard is going to be at the end of
one of the tombstones on the side of a
cliff so it is a very precarious spot
undead bone shard four will be at the
era sale of boreal valley near the
abandoned church or it might be called
the Church of your club on fire you're
going to walk to the woods beside the
bonfire and continue through the woods
follow it wrap around the building and
the shard is going to be behind a
tombstone that's being guarded by one of
those winged monsters from the road of
sacrifices undead bone shard five will
be in the air-filled dungeon overall
area bonier the profaned capital bonfire
this one's really easy it's directly
next to the bonfire there should be a
corpse and if you go up to the corpse
you will get the line down gesture and v
undead bone shard some people have said
it might be after the first gargoyle
fight and might be around a corpse in
the area so keep your eyes out however I
have found it directly next to the
bonfire
number six is going to be at La Fleur
Castle I think at the dragon barracks
bonfire it's basically going to be right
before the two giant dragons that
Spitfire run on the bridge that goes up
to them but right before you finish
crossing the bridge drop down and the
shard is going to be right next to you
under the bridge on that ledge make sure
you don't drop down to the lowest
possible area since you're going to be
on the ledge that you can only get to by
dropping down from the bridge number
seven is again lothric castle
however this one's going to be in
library the grand archives is the area
name this one you should find fairly
easily as you're progressing through it
however it is a bit hard to explain my
best explanation is you're going to pass
all the gargoyles on the roofs and once
you go through the broken window and
near a ladder shortcut this shard is
just gonna be right there on the desk
you should see it you should pick it up
normally so if you haven't gotten this
far you'll probably pick it up normally
however if this is like your final one
and you haven't gotten this that is the
location number eight is going to be the
catacombs of Karthus and that is where
we are going to stay for the remainder
of this list the overall area of the
catacombs of Qarth is not just the one
bonfire for the first one directly after
the spoilers abyss Watchers and spoilers
fight you're going to run down the first
staircase through the rooms until you
get to the second staircase and you're
gonna run down that now be careful
there's gonna be a giant ball of
skeletons that goes down the second
staircase fondly called nito's testicle
you're going to run down the staircase
be careful because nito's testicle will
be falling down to let it go back up and
you're going to go inside and kill the
pointy headed skeleton near where
needlestick testicle hits the parts once
you do this next time you need a
testicle comes through it should bash
open once it hit the bars and the shard
will be in the remnants of the testicle
number nine is gonna be the catacombs of
Karthus again as i said near the demon
ruins bonfire technically this is just
in the general area however the demon
runes bonfire is the best bonfire
to get this one so to get this shard
you're going to have to kill the giant
worm that's in the general overall area
I would say do this from the demon runes
because you're going to be towards its
backside so it'll be really easy
pickings for you to just whittle it down
wait Whittle it down wait Whittle it
down and once you kill it you will be
rewarded with a shard and I think some
form of magic finally number 10 again
catacombs are Karthus this one is going
to be near the old King's antechamber
bonfire this one is a little more
complicated in terms of getting to it so
you're going to want to follow where I
go in the video from the old King's
antechamber you're going to be running
through multiple rooms until you get to
a very large room with multiple flying
fireballs and fireball monsters in the
room this is the largest room in the
area that I found that is not in the
upper area so in the lower ruins and the
shard is going to be at the end of this
room on the left be careful because a
slime is going to drop from the ceiling
when you pick the shard up and it can
kill you especially because there's a
lot of stuff happening in the room as
you can see I died when I picked it up
so I just really want to get I knew
where it was beforehand I really wanted
to get it I didn't want to have to deal
with fighting all those guys so I just
sprinted through it and once you get
this
go back to your bonfire at Firelink
shrine level up your SS flask using all
the shards you've gotten or if you've
been leveling it up level up the final
time you should get the achievement
ultimate bonfire and you have your Estus
flask at +10 hope you guys enjoy this
video many thanks to from the ashes 984
a redditor that created a basic list for
all 10 bone shards I created this video
after seeing the list the list did help
me in collecting a couple of the bone
shards that were a little harder to find
for me so I really appreciate that from
the ashes and I hope you guys have
enjoyed this video hope you guys have
gotten all 10 of your undead bone shards
and been able to max out your SS flex so
your helium for all that health if you
really liked this video make sure you
check out more of my channel as I have
other Dark Souls 3 videos up and I will
be continuing to post a lot of Dark
Souls 3 content because I really like
this game and I know this can be a tough
game and I'm happy to give as many tips
as I can to people who haven't gotten a
chance to play it who are new to it and
with the series having a tough time is
anything I appreciate you guys watching
peace out